what's up guys welcome back to yet
another video of elf fame it's pretty
safe to say at this point that this week
is gonna be a bit of a marathon of elf
fame basically because this is by far my
biggest priority at the moment I do
still have other things that I am
planning like the Boneshaker POV don't
worry about that that's definitely
coming up and just my regular City
skylines and Park detect things that I
want to return to in the future as well
but at the moment I just move those into
the background to be able to finish this
thing before the 1st of July which is
when the deadline for the competition is
and I also have to say finishing the
coaster itself is a bigger priority for
me at the moment than the making of this
series so I'm kind of lagging behind
already and that's why the rest of this
week might become a bit of a marathon
because I am recording these time lapses
out of ridiculous rate just because I'm
trying to push this thing out there and
actually working on a pretty hard but I
end up with not as much time to do the
commentaries and render these videos and
get them onto YouTube and it's not as
important so I might end up deleting
more footage than I well I have
predicted beforehand or having the order
of the video is a bit messed up like
uploading the final video before I
actually get all the time lapses out
though I definitely hope that is not
going to be the case things like that
might happen so just in case there might
not be to great features of
professionalism from my side this week
just because I'm trying to push this
ride out and that's basically the main
thing I'm concerned with at the moments
awkward voice crack though to actually
talk about what's happening in the video
for a second I'm working on the station
which is a pretty big thing and probably
something I wanted to start this video
off with and it's a pretty big thing for
a few reasons
it's obviously it's a big building mmm
yeah it's gonna be the biggest building
of the entire park actually at least in
terms of footprints it's a very good
opportunity to get some scenery around
this area because it's pretty tight over
here with the track and the transfer
tracks and just the coasters and paths
all around this area so having that
station has a very heavy part of the
scenery is gonna help with that in the
future but it's also kind of
Portland's because it's more or less the
blueprints for what the scenery in the
rest of this area is gonna look like
because basically I want to go for an
elven village kind of idea and while at
the moment I have built the castle as
the single building in this park at the
moment it's not really a good
representation of what the entire area
is gonna look like scenery wise because
the idea is that I have this castle
sitting on a hill but around that's on
the smaller Hills the issues can be
there sprawling elven village which is
gonna be the scenery around the ride and
it's that sort of I could take here
which I'll be more or less getting the
inspiration for with this station which
is gonna be a very basic idea of what
everything in terms of how everything is
going to look like revolves around and
there are a couple of build a couple
like basic building ideas that you can
see in this station that I want to keep
in the rest of the village which is
gonna be the roof shape in general I
want to go for some pretty regular roofs
actually um it's there quite a bit like
the roofs in Rivendell the only
difference is that the top parts arches
upward a little bit just to give it well
a bit of extra flare I'd say make it a
little bit less boring than just a
straight roof though aside from that
they're very typical Rivendell ish
groups especially with the gables on the
side an important detail in these
buildings is going to be the detail
right underneath the roofs so a lot of
details gonna sit in the gables on the
sides but also a bit actually on the top
of the roof like this and I'll try to
make the trims around the roofs pretty
fancy and another really important
building and very distinguishing feature
of these buildings is gonna be the
arches that I want to have underneath
the buildings they're gonna be pretty
simple in terms of shape they're all
more or less gonna have these types of
roofs with these types of Gables but the
biggest parts of them will probably be
made up of the arches that I want to
have in the buildings I don't just have
straight walls but I kind of just want
to make more open buildings with a lot
of arches and going for the kind of
Gothic arches not the round arches but
the ones that
points upwards with basically these
pillar pieces which work quite nicely
for them they're pretty small pieces so
you can shape the arches out of them
pretty nicely they also have this nice
very fancy texture on the side it is
gonna be a bit of an issue for my PC
like at this point in time I still had a
decent frame rate in this park but I
don't really recommend using pieces in
this way if you really want to preserve
your computer but I am really happy with
how the general idea for the arches came
out so I'll basically be supporting all
of the roofs with a lot of arches like
this with pillars between them and that
is more or less going to be the general
style of this town so you can already
recognize bit quite a bit actually of
what the entire scenery is going to look
like in this station I actually wanted
to make this gable over here as well and
this is something to talk about a bit
maybe when it comes to the roofs of
these buildings a lot of the like Alvin
village looks that you very often see in
books and films etc is very strange it's
like with curved moves with all sorts of
shapes that you don't normally see and
it's that kind of thing which I figured
for a while I could go with over here
but in the end I figured it would just
be easier to go with a more Rivendell
style roof just go with a simple gable
roof that is kind of recognizable not
too crazy are not too fancy like and
just make sure that I get the more
interesting and unique details and in
other ways and with the roof as well I
figured it would be nice to have these
simple roofs but actually be able to get
some more strange and Elvidge roofs in
in other ways so I wanted to go for
these very round upward-pointing dormers
and with some strange-looking elven
towers which you'll see later on in this
video so that's the kind of approach I
wanted to take here and why the roofs
themselves are pretty simple in shape
but why I wanted to go with this kind of
dormer and I think that's kind of idea
that it's simple but that it has like
more strange and elvish like details to
it I think describes the entire
buildings style pretty neatly like if
you just look at the general shapes of
these buildings
it's gonna be pretty simple most of them
aren't just going to be rectangular
simple buildings with not too much weird
things going on no too much sticking out
not too weird and unusual composition
kind of ideas there just can be straight
buildings with simple roofs but with the
details bringing out and the more
fantasy aspects to them and you know
towers and dormer is bringing out a bit
more of the stranger and more unusual
shapes in these buildings and that kind
of applies to this station is well one
of the biggest challenges that I felt
for this station is the fact that it's
on a square footprint
you might have heard actually very
understandably - a very common tip which
says that you want to avoid building
buildings with a square footprint as
much as you can because it's just one of
the easiest ways to end up with a really
depthless boring looking building even
if you add a lot of detail to it because
basically it's just gonna end up looking
like a box it's not gonna have anything
to bring up the depth or make it more
interesting to look at and even if you
add a lot of detail to it it's just
gonna look like a very detailed box
which doesn't make that great of a
difference
and I would reckon it is more
interesting actually to look at a
building that has a really interesting
composition and is engaging that way
than just a square building with a lot
of detail put onto it and that's one of
the reasons why I did feel this building
was a bit challenged challenging to get
right since it is on the square foot
prints and one of the things that I
really wanted to try and do here is to
still make it look as interesting as I
could and as unsquare as I could
especially from this side here even
though it is on the square footprint in
the end and what I try to kind of do is
have this smaller roof that kind of
hangs over on the left side here and
have a higher roof but that doesn't hang
over as much and is more - at the end of
the building on the right side and have
that very flats kind of balcony looking
part on the right side as well to make
sure that even though it's all built
pretty much on the square the roofs
aren't following that Square and are
more offset in that sense just to make
it look less obvious that it is
built on this square foundation and it
doesn't entirely work at the moment yet
but it's also going to work in the
future with adding some rock work around
this part and maybe a few parts that
kind of stick out from the building here
and there and foliage around it to kind
of mask the fact that it's just such a
blocky building if you look basically
from right above the building it's still
gonna look like a square but I try to
add things and remove things here and
there to make sure that it doesn't look
blocky if you look at it from the side
and that's basically why I wanted to
build it in the way that I've done so at
the moment so I would say it's not that
bad of a thing to build buildings in a
square shape especially in the cases
where it's pretty much just littered to
do so like if you're making a Main
Street or if you just want to have a
pretty simple square building in any
case it's definitely far from a mistake
but in this case since it is a fantasy
theme and the station is pretty
important to look at and I wanted
something more interesting than just one
very simple thing not to mention that if
I went for one roof following the exact
shape of the building here I would have
had an absolutely enormous roof so
that's also another good reason why I
wanted to use more different smaller
roofs that kind of come into and out of
each other here but yeah working with a
square footprint isn't actually always
that bad but in a case like this just by
adding these different roofs in
different directions and kind of parts
that stick out in different ways it can
still work pretty well if you have a
building on a square foot prints what I
wanted to do over here is add a quick
transfer track which is pretty simple
actually
it also doesn't technically work and
this is something I also want to address
for a bit I've gotten many comments
about why I add these things around here
but basically realistically
rollercoasters have a transfer track
especially at this side they at this
size they don't always have transfer
tracks but the larger rollercoasters
always do to be able to store their
trains so I wanted to have a transfer
track right before they station for both
of these coasters but there wasn't a lot
of space left and the problem with the
purple coaster here is that
there is definitely a huge lack of space
and the way that a transfer track
usually works is there's a part where it
switches where there's a track that can
move over a rail to lead to another
track which goes into a storage building
but over here I didn't really have space
for a storage building or a storage rail
so these storage rail is on the transfer
track itself and realistically it would
have to move two tracks to be able to
transport one car to the trends for
track which is stored on the transfer
track which is really strange so
technically it's not very much a working
thing but I figured better have a kind
of reared unusual transfer track than
nothing at all so that's why I went with
that and I guess I could also repeat
King rct3 words which are absolutely
genius and I'll use as a reply to
everything from now on
this transfer trecherous uses elven
magic and that's how it basically works
and that's how I'll try to refute every
single criticism that I get this coaster
is gonna do a lot of unusual stuff and
even though I'm gonna try to basically
make it as if it could be parts of a
real theme park there are just some
parts which are kind of impossible and
there was a pretty much fixed with elven
magic so that's something I'm not too
worried about um and I also wanted to
add a bit of rock work over here it's
not too much and most of the rock work
is something that I do gonna do in like
streams or just on my own instead of
recording it because this ride is gonna
have to feature a lot of it and it's not
all that interesting to look at it's
mostly just more of the same basically
but I didn't want to feature a bit of
rock work here especially since it is
pretty important in dressing up the area
around the station here one of the
things that this station is gonna kind
of be like is this sort of hidden inside
the forest kind of idea and that's what
a lot of this ride is gonna have but
this the station in particular because
it really sits in this valley between
the hills surrounding this area and the
big hill where the council sits on so
it's kind of gonna be hidden among trees
and walk work pretty much all around it
and you're never going to be able to see
the entire station from any
erection and that's kind of the idea
that I want to go for like this sort of
secret hidden elven house in the forest
which a lot of the general surrounding
area is gonna have but the station more
so because I know when I have some elven
village parts in this park as well and
they're not gonna be as densely foliage
that's the word and they're gonna be a
bit more visible and prominent than the
station which really sits in this valley
down here and the foliage surrounding it
is going to be a bit exaggerated as well
because even though I do want to make
this sort of general and realistic
coaster and you do see rollercoasters
with quite dense foliage especially
nemesis I think is pretty cool idea of
like dense foliage around a sort of
rocky terrain with the terrain inverts I
do want to make this bit more dense and
mixed up then you would realistically
commonly see especially around scenery
like this and also on a scale of these
courses because they are really large
coasters and the foliage will be really
dense and varied so really a lot of
flowers and bushes pretty much
everywhere which I wouldn't realistic
lycée you should do because there's just
too much and in a real Park that would
have to be people to actually maintain
all that which is why flower beds for
outside paths is a bad idea generally
but it's something I kind of want to
ignore here just use the elfin magic to
care for all the plants here and just
make the area a bit more fancy than I
normally realistically would because in
the end it's a bit of a fantasy over
here as well now moving on to the last
part of this video this is kind of a fun
part I'm adding the final Tower of the
station which is something that I only
added after the rest of the station was
done I always had a bit of like in an
empty spot over here and I never really
knew what I wanted to do with it and
when the station like the rest of the
station was done I was looking at it for
a while and figured it doesn't work that
well it kind of lacks a real center
point of attention and I figured a nice
way to get that and give it a nicer
conversation in general would be to add
a tower beside it and it also helps to
bring a bit more elven man
Check Into the station because at this
point it still kind of looks like a
general Alpine building even if it has
all of these Alvin asked touches to it
and this tower is really gonna look very
elvish and not very much like anything
in real life definitely has that Alvin
kind of moved to it with a slight curve
and slightly pointing to what the side I
don't know have a spire in the middle of
it so really interesting and unusual
roof shape which was also kind of a pain
to behold for a while but I'm actually
pretty happy with how it works out it's
definitely something I want to keep
trying a bit more with spires and
dormers just because it brings out the
Alvin idea pretty well without being too
obnoxious and without being too out of
this world and too strange of the shape
to fit in with these somewhat alright
normal-looking buildings of this area in
general so it's the one fancy Tower over
here it has a pretty narrow base when
you compare it actually to the width of
the tower roof itself just to make that
roof and the top part of the tower come
out a little bit more I guess this could
be a clock tower but there's really no
use for it it's just a piece of scenery
for the station to make it look a bit
more interesting and what I wanted to do
with it over here I was figuring for a
while I could just have simple windows
on the side of the building but it just
ended up not really working and not
being something that I really like that
much
speaking of windows in towers I'm still
gonna get back to the windows in the
towers with the console because yeah
realistically like many people said
there would be spiral staircases in
those towers and it would make no sense
to have four windows and all four sides
of the tower on the same height
if the staircase inside of it is in a
spiral shape so I'll definitely get back
to that
but in this tower I wanted to not have
that many windows and go for a nice
little pattern on the side instead which
adds a bit of elven magic to it as well
a bit of like fancy the kind of row is
growing plant ish idea to it which
turned out to not be that great to make
and actually forgot to make this into
one building so I had to end up making
it again for the other sides anyway I
still have a few cinematic shots then
I've got so I'll show those and just
leave you at nuts so I think it goes for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time